you have quite the potty mouth you I am
experienced it yes you do drink some
toilets I don't mean she drinks from
toilets I'm saying you more than almost
anyone I've met you you'll just throw
out the swears like a sailor on shore
leave learning this about myself I just
now loner
I have been telling you for years
personality dysmorphia but has it ever
been an you know an issue like today at
the panel there actually had to be a
sign that said remember there's some
people here who are under 18 years of
age it's almost like they wrote that
just for you Josh decided that they did
write that just for me
obviously yeah now is it true there's a
rumor that you guys set up a swear jar
on the set of Hunger Games
yeah not like for each other they
initially were his children yeah when
when like when squeeze first had like
the season the willow when she was
younger and like 10 years old and she's
around her in us and like what like just
did you hear it right right now I hear
[ __ ] all the time
right I'm not swearing yeah well here's
what I was thinking I was thinking maybe
we could try and use this special talent
of viewers for good we have a swear jar
right here and what we thought we'd do
is wearing his hearing and
I have several thousand dollars here and
here's what we're going to do you're
gonna need it guys what we're gonna do
all right I will put a hundred dollars
into this swear jar for every swear you
can say in 30 seconds and then I will
double that amount and all the money
will go to the charity of your ru right
you're gonna have 30 seconds on the
clock and remember this is for the kid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
present world view I'm not good at money
and such I'm guessing that's around
$5,000 we'll double it $10,000 to your
charity wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]